after weeks drifting at Sea the first
full day on dry land 185 rohingya
refugees came ashore in Indonesia's ache
Province on Monday evening weak Hungary
and many severely dehydrated
we left the refugee camp in Bangladesh
seven days into the journey the boat
engine broke about 10 days into the
journey our food was finished I had to
drink sea water after more than a month
we arrived here many died on the sea
this was a scene just hours earlier as
the survivors finally reached land these
people are two-time refugees fleeing
first from persecution in Myanmar for
which its military government is facing
charges of genocide at the international
court of justice and then from harsh
conditions in refugee camps in
Bangladesh
in Bangladesh our children didn't get
educated we couldn't leave the camp we
didn't have food we didn't have anything
in late November Aid agencies saved four
boats left Bangladesh
on December the 8th an Indonesian oil
tanker picked up a boat carrying about
150 people off the Myanmar coast and
towed it to shore ten days later the Sri
Lankan Navy rescued 104 people off Sri
Lanka's North Coast the captain said
he'd received an SOS message from a
third boat which he feared was about to
sink on Sunday a group of 58 rohingya
came ashore in ladong village in
Indonesia's Western ache Province and on
Monday evening the boat carrying 185
landed further up the coast it's not yet
clear whether this is the boat feared
lost a week earlier
uh we need to do further communication
and intensive investigation with
different parties within Indonesia or
outside of Indonesia to clarify if this
is the case at the moment I cannot
confirm the information
for now Indonesians are doing what they
can to give these refugees some sense of
normality and dignity after their ordeal
but their future remains unclear Aid
agencies say the number of rohingya
fleeing by boat from refugee camps in
Bangladesh has risen five-fold this year
to nearly two and a half thousand the
fear is that many more will be subject
to these sorts of dangers in the months
to come Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera